[Music]
life's not fair
visit my little friend while some are
born to feast others spend their lives
in the dark
[Music]
begging for scraps
everything you see
exist together in a delicate balance
[Music]
while others search for what they can
take a true king searches for what he
can give
[Music]
run away Simba
never return
you must take your place
[Music]
and the circle of life
[Music]
I'm gonna get one of those vultures one
day I'm gonna get one I don't know why
it's so important to you I just feel
like you would make me feel better oh no
it's a little lion that is not alive
well then go check out what it's not a
lion it's a furry bird it looks like a
lion it's not let me get a closer look
excuse me all right let me see what
we're dealing with here it's a lion it
gets bigger can we please keep him oh I
promise I'll walk in every day if he
makes a little mess I'll clean it up
you'll be his little mess he's gonna eat
you and then use my body as a toothpick
but one day when he's big and strong
side I've got it what if he's on our
side hear me out having a ferocious lion
around might not be such a bad idea well
can't we keep him yes of course we can
keep it well God who is the brains of
this operation we're gonna name him Fred
this Gorge is where all lions come to
find their raw alliance even my dad even
Mufasa came here when he was your age
refused to leave until his roar could be
heard above the rim all the way up there
that's when you know you found it with a
little practice you'll never be called a
cub again watch this
you'll get it Simba
just takes time I'll check on you later
dad will be so proud Bonnie it's a gift
he'll never forget
look Oh son he lives in new Lion King
was a story that people knew intimately
Simba
the reason the Lion King has endured is
because the inspiration that we're
getting from it is universal it's a
story that remains true to everybody
the songs were amazing just felt like
everything you want from a Disney movie
getting to relive it in a new way is
really exciting what's the model I'm
entering into Lion King inheriting all
that I learned on Jungle Book there was
a tremendous opportunity to retell the
story using a new set of tools and a new
technology Jon just seems to have it all
there is really impressive how he just
sort of holds that all together that I'd
really admire the vast array of talent
that's been assembled for this film it's
a privilege to be counted among these
actors yeah let me come I can help no
son you stay with the other Cubs and
then the music there was such a rich
tradition surrounding the songs that
Hans and Elton and Tim Rice and now
Pharrell worked on all so that's nice to
have actors who are both the performers
and the singers you have Beyonce and
Donald they present something totally
new and exciting you have to take your
place as king these are real musicians
bringing their creative voices to this
hakuna matata you guys sounded great
this has been a really incredible
experience I've never seen anything made
this way before the level of care where
everybody knows how much it means and
everybody's that invested seeing you
again you don't know what this will mean
to everyone I love the idea of audiences
rediscovering something you know that
it's gonna be very compelling and
exciting
[Music]
we wanted to capture what people's
memory was of this with both the music
and the imagery I think when you can
capture the spirit but show them
something new and surprising sort of the
best combo it is dying
can you feel the love tonight look at
the stars the PC the Greek kings look
down on us from those stars
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and so will I Disney's The Lion King
rated PG tickets on sale now you know
why it's so important to you with this
film we wanted to honor the past but we
also wanted to do something fresh
part of that is casting you're gonna
love it here this place is amazing I
really love the Lion King so I feel
really blessed to be a part of it it was
just crazy getting such an iconic role
let's do this I was super excited John
gave JT and I so much freedom to create
that great relationship between young
knowledge young Simba pinja you owe me
an apology I've seen 55 let's just play
around with it for an animator which
incredibly valuable is the performance
of the actor so instead of doing motion
capture we wanted to film the actors
performing together as much as possible
most people get a bigger reaction when
we say okay so we got a very human
performance at the heart of this rate
technical film how much research did I
do I've been living as a meerkat for
about four years now but I still kept my
phone who is the brains of this
operation I research how hyenas and
lions actually don't like each other at
all that's perfect cuz I am starving if
you're asking me whether I lived as a
bird for six months no all I have is
this voice louder or softer the cast is
just amazing and we're excited to have
beyond saying there's no and I think
it's very important that mr. James Earl
Jones came back for the voice and fossa
remember who you are this has been a
really incredible experience I don't
think there has been anything made this
way before it's just beautiful
you see he lives in you it's wonderful
to have the tremendous opportunity to
bring something fresh and new and
different while still maintaining the
spirit the original Lion King
everything the light touches
is all kingdom but a keys time is ruler
rises and falls like the Sun
one day the Sun was set on my time here
and will rise with you as the new king
[Music]
remember
[Music]